[Music]
tumult of the zelda breath of the wild
release PlatinumGames has a little uh
well planet memes worked on it you know
square enix revealed released near
automata do you say automata or automata
it depends on my mood
like I say automata uh released it's
really good we gave it a 9 out of 10
Miguel concepción who's not here right
now he is reviewing Ghost Recon
wildlands giving 9 out of 10 I like I
said it's platinum action game if you're
into like memorizing revengeance yeah
say the whole thing I think he called it
like a Susan sudo sequel yeah yeah it's
you know it's about androids that come
back down from the moon to clear the
earth of robots to try to reclaim it for
humanity sold already sold yeah and it's
the sequel to near which was yeah like
still not totally like clear and like
how they're connected in plain air
it's like known as a cult classic but
it's it's kind of weird 2011 I believe
done 10 earlier than that yeah a gets
earlier than that like 2009 I'm just
gonna counting but anyway uh Pete you
played a little bit of it there was a
there's a problem with a bug where the
PlayStation menu would say it was done
installing and downloading so you would
go to play it and then you beat this
like maybe hour-long intro and then
it'll go to this menu screen I said it's
not done downloading but you also to
save in this game from like a few hours
I played you need to be around these
certain modules and if you're not you
can't save it so then at that point you
either have to restart the game once
it's finished installing and you lose
all that progress that was me yeah but I
should say there's a patch that I chose
not to install before I started playing
no nice so that's my fault
why did you why because I literally had
like a few hours of play and I was like
I want to cuz he was eating muzzled what
the potstickers last night right yeah
you were busy thinking I guess her but
it'll wasted on pot stickers and Zelda
um
this games fun you kind of you can see
here if you're watching video you have
pods and whatnot these are
kind of affect your abilities also give
you the ranged attack but you can tell
it's that you know Bayonetta Metal Gear
Rising combat it's pretty frantic heavy
light attacks within dodging you know
juggling maneuvers and whatnot pretty
stylized but the game starts off they're
different from the footage we're looking
at right now yes it starts off you
piloting essentially a mech in flight
mode all your comrades get shot down
then you have to sort of navigate like a
few scenes where you're going up against
other ships it's very much like an old
arcade shooting game you know and that
was like a really nice treat at the
beginning particularly because I like
that stuff and I noticed some of the
things that have borrowed from across
that genre which is nice to see it was
almost like the developers were like we
love shoot-'em-ups we just want to do
something with this yeah and her funsies
in and it was a really fun little intro
but the next thing that really struck me
about this game was yes the combat is
great the world is interesting to look
at the soundtrack is really good yeah
people chatter mentioning there right
now because the first thing people
mentioned like these like broke like
organs going on like it's a really
interesting tone with like the Gothic
sort of outfits that the characters are
wearing um yet there's the thing that
stuck out to me the most even from
before I got to check it out even just I
sit next to me also watching him play um
was that this game has so much style
yeah uh from the UI which I actually
really love the UI it's gorgeous
looks like Metal Gear yeah we even
regular Metal Gear games yeah which like
I don't normally I mean I care about a
bad UI more than I care about a good UI
you know um but I think it's really
really beautiful um but also just the
the style like she's very chic I love
her outfit there's even a very cheeky if
you will trophy yeah for winning that
for looking up her skirt because people
were kind of complaining about her
outfit but I would cosplay it it's
awesome um but on top of that I mean you
can see here like she her style
transcends just her outfit and goes into
the way she moves and and the movement
really stuck out to me as well Archangel
337 1 and the twitch chat was asking is
this heaven new game plus mode one thing
Miguel liked about it was that you can
I'm almost like spoiling things on I
know
our multiple endings yeah you can play
see it from different perspectives like
what's the Rashomon sure which is like I
think for good way to do that but I I'm
kind of exasperated because I knew they
were multiple endings and her day with
her are like four or five or five I
think 26 26 each letter of the alphabet
in weight and I thought there were five
multiple endings near on I just said
there are 26 multiple really ah
that's but you can also let yeah you see
things from different perspectives
you're being you're to be in the lot of
footage we're watching now but then you
also have a - 9 s was your the character
boy but what if your boy oh it's - Eve's
boy yeah buddy boy
to be or not to be boy we just build a
bo I I should want you guys need to cut
me off and I go into Delma jokes like
that I really like how this game shifts
like you mentioned Pete from like a
bullet-hell to this top-down kind of
almost sometimes isometric but then it
becomes a side-scrolling platformer at
some points yeah the camera itself say
action games kind of live and die by
their camera and in this game you see
this right here
you're it like piloting your mech form
yeah it switches really well between
them then you hear the top-down view
right here it's a good time at games
like he's like a twin stick shooter at
that sure yeah you'd think it would be
overwhelming but it's not yeah like you
get a especially with the I take
exception with the term bullet hell if
if I'm a very specific genre of shoot
him up in this one yeah doesn't quite
hit that but okay it is still kind of
frantic but you do have the ability to
chop down the bullets that are coming at
you with your sword
oh so unlike most shooting games where
you have to simply dodge them yeah now
you get a chance to actually like blow
them away and like a few games in the
genre had done it seemed for a minute
because the ship you had would like
transfer between like black and white I
was like are they gonna bring you Khader
go mechanics into this but that sadly
did not come to pass maybe it will I'm
only a you know an hour in the game oh
so stylish I love it Harajuku in the
future yeah Miguel who had reviewed it
and he was saying one of his most
positive ways was a story it's a Yoko
taro mm-hmm the director who's kind of
known for this weird stylized world did
the first near mm-hm that's still very
much present here despite the fact that
platinum worked on the action segments
these robots are kind of cute the ones
that you're fighting the whole time yeah
they look dumb they look
but very endearing lead um but even yet
even within the first hour they they
ramped up in an interesting way it's not
like necessarily novel but very rapidly
the game is like okay these guys only
have melee attacks now they have melee
and ranged attacks now they're wearing
armor or like now you know it's they
keep ramping up the difficulty in the
variable is it to juggle very quickly
yeah a lot of people are mentioning
PlatinumGames kind of needed this yes
yes because what TMNT was the last one
they released yes is kind of weird
transformers is the only one that really
struck a chord with people and even then
it was like yes because it's a basic
game and it does the basics fine but
it's been a while since I've had their
own game really sure yeah but yeah this
game is fun I've only played there's 26
different endings I've only played like
150 second of this game like what that
fragile endings I think that counted for
like she's too big by the way you die or
like if you do status later
no that's yeah so like I got an ending
technically because I died so when you
die lime starts to scroll to credits oh
yeah yeah and it like goes right through
them right and so there's yeah there's a
lot of like weird you know quote-unquote
endings but even within that like a
there's one I'd love to spoil this
morning it's not really story related
it's almost like a surprising mechanic
the ending introduces yeah there's just
a lot of unexpected things to come
across during the game but then also
after you finish it mm-hmm I feel like
I'll get really into the weeds with it a
bit later on because there's just so
much competing for my attention right
now but I'm seriously obsessed with her
dress like her outfit I can't stop
thinking about it
and that makes me want to play it on top
of everything else I don't think they
ever really bother from what Miguel was
saying to justify why the androids are
dressed like that because your guitar
does well yeah I don't care [ __ ] it yeah
I know he literally I think went on
Twitter and was like people are
complaining about her but send me all
your but fan art like he's just kind of
ad yet no apologies like this is what
this is what I like it's what I do
go find that later yeah so between their
licensed games and their kind of recent
failures and then scalebound being
canceled this is good for platinum games
out saying having worked on the action
parts of Nier automata so if you want to
go
read deeper into it Miguel concepción x'
review was up on gamespot again he gave
it a 9 out of 10 uh that game is out now
so go play it's very good if you don't
have anything else to play which you
probably do but uh yeah not to take away
from near automata but go check that out
and then I you know leave your comments
in the review leave your comments on
this video if you're watching us on
YouTube or games right after the fact
and let us know what you think about it
[Music]